hey guys my name is Jess McDowell it is
a sixth of October today and I got some
gaming news all ready to go for your
Monday so let's see what's one metal
gear solid 5 ground zeroes has a release
date for PC as of today the game will
appear on steam on December 18 and it's
going to support 4k resolution which is
sweet if your system can handle it
beyond that the pc version is also set
to feature increased shadow resolution
more simultaneous light sources and an
increase to the number of on-screen
character models shown at the same time
metal gear solid 5 the phantom pain is
also going to Rive on pc but it seems
we'll have to wait a little longer to
find out when exactly microsoft didn't
do too badly in their first week of
selling xbox one's in china if chinese
media reports are to be believed third
reports translated by Kotaku indicate
that 100,000 units may have been sold in
the first seven days on the Xbox one
being on shelves the console is the
first to be legally sold in the country
in over a decade as a result of China's
console ban in 2000 which was lifted in
September of last year a report from
Chinese games site 1717 3.com suggested
that Shanghai media group who owns
Microsoft's Chinese Xbox partner best TV
wants to sell over 1 million xbox one
systems by October 2015 finally today
Ubisoft have told videogamer that they
weren't able to push Assassin's Creed
unity to 1080p and 60 frames per second
on either new generation console as
they'd hoped Ubisoft were reportedly
targeting the lofty benchmark but came
in just short at 900p and 30 frames per
second on the ps4 and the Xbox one while
that news isn't so surprising what is
strange is senior producer von some pom
Brion's comment that Ubisoft chose to
keep the resolutions and frame rates
equal to avoid inflaming the console war
he says we decided to lock them at the
same specs to avoid all the debates and
stuff apparently you
he is being held back by the consoles
processes which need to handle the AI
and the number of NPCs on screen palm
pre on went on to explain it's not the
number of polygons that affects the
frame rate we could be running at 100
frames per second if it was just
graphics but because of the AI we're
still limited to 30 frames per second as
for your question of the day let me know
what you think about one console being
held back by another in the interest of
keeping things equal that is it for me
in your Monday Joseph news I'll be back
same time tomorrow with a bunch more
thing so I hope to see you then